نبدا النشره من تركيا التي تعرضت قبل قليل
الى هزه ارضيه قويه قال مركز الزلازل
الامريكي انه قدر شدتها والتي ضربت وسط
وجنوب تركيا بسبعه فاصله تسعه درجات على
مقياس ريختر فيما افادى المركز الالماني
بان الزلزال وقع على عمق عشره كيلومترات
واكدت مصادر العربيه ان
زلزال تركيا شعر به سكان مناطق في لبنان
والعراق ومصر
واليونان ايضا اذا الزملاء يفيدوننا بهذه
المعلومه على كل حال المزيد من التفاصيل
حول هذا الزلزال ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف من
اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان زنكلو زيدان
اين وقع الزلزال وتداعياته
نعم ابراهيم وقع زلزال في منطقه بازار
تشيك التابعه لولايه كهرمان مرعش في جنوب
تركيا
الزلزال بحسب هيئه الكوارث التركيه افاد
بلغت شدته
7.4 وبعمق سبعه كيلو مترات وقع في تمام
الساعه الرابعه وسبعه عشر دقيقه بالتوقيت
المحلي طبعا كل الولايات المجاوره شعرت
بالزلزال جميع سكان الولايات تقريبا في
ولايات غازي عنتاب ملاطيا كهرمان مرعش
وايضا في قيصري وايضا في هاتاي واضنه كل
سكان هذه الولايات نزلوا الى الشوارع طبعا
تركيا تمر اليوم بظروف جويه سيئه هناك
ثلوج في معظم الولايات سواء كان في
اسطنبول او انقره او حتى في مناطق الجنوب
التركي لذلك الجو بارد جدا وجميع السكان
نزلوا الى الشوارع تواصلنا مع عدد من
السكان في من استطعنا الوصول اليهم في هذا
التوقيت في ولايه غازي عنتاب اخبرونا
بانهم شعروا بالزلزال تقريبا استمرت مده
الزلزال بين حوالي يعني الفتره التي احس
فيها
بقوه الزلزال بين نصف دقيقه الى الدقيقه
طبعا حتى الان الاخبار التي وردتنا ايضا
في مناطق في شمال سوريا
تعرضت للهزه او شعره بالزلزال وكان هناك
ايضا بعض الاضرار حتى الان الانباء عن
اضرار ماديه في سواء كانت في جنوب تركيا
او حتى في شمال سوريا هناك اضرار ماديه
بحسب ما وصاني قبل قليل ايضا تواصل معي
اصدقاء من دمشق العاصمه السوريه ايضا
شعروا بالزلزال لذلك نتحدث عن زلزال بقوه
7.4
زلزال شديد نتحدث مبدئيا عن اضرار ماديه
فقط نستوضح منك المناطق التي ضربها
الزلزال هي مناطق ماهوله بالس عن طبيعه
البناء في هذه المناطق وهل هناك مباني
مقاومه للزلازل نعرف انه منذ العامه 1999
بعد زلزال اسطنبول هناك معايير جديده
للبناء الى اي مدى قد تكون هذه المناطق
تضررت
نعم حتى الان منطقه بازارجيك التي وهي
مركز الزلزال لا نملك معلومات
كافيه حول طبيعه هذه المنطقه هي يعني كل
ما استطعت جمعهم المعلومات هي منطقه في
ريف ولايه كهرمان مرعش بطبيعه الحال كما
ذكرت منذ عقدين او اكثر هناك معايير خاصه
لكل الامنيه الجديده في تركيا يجب اي بناء
جديد ان يحمل مواصفات مقاومه للزلازل
وبالتالي يعني نامل ان لا تكون الاضرار
البشريه او لا يكون هناك اضرار البشريه
لكن بحسب ما وصلتنا المعلومات اوليه نعم
هناك اضرار بعض الابنيه انهارت في بعض
المناطق لنتحدث عن ولايات في ملاطيا وايضا
في كهرمان مرعش هذه انباء اوليه حتى الان
لا نملك معلومات اكيد لكن بالعموم كما
ذكرت اي بناء جديد حتى يح على رخصه بناء
يجب ان يحصل على موافقه او معايير خاصه في
الزلازل حتى الان الاضرار التي نتحدث عن
اضافه الى طبعا المناطق في تركيا كما
علمنا في حتى الان في ولايه ملاطيا وفي
ولايه
وايضا في كهرمان انباء عن هبوط بعض
الامنيه في شمال سوريا هناك في بعض القرى
القريبه من الحدود التركيه ايضا هناك بوصي
بعض الابنيه هذه اذا كان هناك
سقوط لمباني في شمال سوريا كما ذكرنا شعر
بهذا الزلزال سكان محافظات مصريه قبرص
اليونان العراق لبنان وسوريا وبالتالي
الزلازل التي سبقت كان هناك زلازل في
نوفمبر من العام 2022 وايضا في العام 2020
هل سبق وان شعر سكان الدول المحيطه
بهذا الزلزال بقوته وتداعيات
نعم الذي تحدثت عنه كان في ولايه دودج وهي
ولايه قريبه من اسطنبول في شمال تركيا
كانت شده زلزال وقع على ما اعتقد في
الثانيه والعشرين من
تشرين الثاني وكانت شده الزلزال حين خمسه
على مقياس ريختار شعر السكان اسطنبول
حينها وحينها كانت على الاصابات تقريبا 46
شخصا اصيبوا بهذا الزلزال بحسب الارقام
التي صدرت حينها لكن نتحدث اليوم نحن عن
زلزال بشده اكبر
7.4 يعني حتى الان يعني كما
نتحدث وفقا وانت تتحدث ايضا بانه هذا
الزلزال استمر لنحو 30 ثانيه هذا عنصر هام
ربما يكون معنا خبير زلازل ليخبرنا عن
الفرق حول اهميه مده الزلزال
نعم انا اتحدث هنا عن ما سمعته قبل قليل
من بعض الاشخاص الذين تحدثنا اليهم على
على عجاله
انهم شعروا بهذه الهزه قرابه 30 ثانيه ومن
ثم غادروا البناء هذا الكلام كان في ولايه
ملاطيا وايضا ولايه غازي عنتاب تقريبا نفس
المده شهر بها السكان هناك
نتوقع يعني شده هذا الزلزال كبيره نرجو ان
لا يكون هناك اضرار بشريه لكن حتى الان
الانباء التي تريدنا سواء كان من جنوب
تركيا او من شمال سوريا هناك انهيار في
بعض الابنيه
لا ندري حتى الان كل التفاصيل عن
بعض هذه الابنيه في مناطق قبل قليل اتابع
وانا معكم مع الهواء احد الابنيه التجاريه
كان متضررا في ولايه مراطيه لكن لا ندري
ان كان هناك ابنيه سكنيه او كان في هذه
الامنيه سكان حتى الان المعلومات ما زالت
شحيحه والاخبار تاتي بشكل عاجل من عده
ولايات
سنعطيك بعض الوقت لكي تجمع لنا مزيد من
المعلومات زيدان ثم نعود لاستكمال الحديث
معك لكن دعنا نتحول الى مراسله العربيه من
بيروت ويتم غنوه تسمعيني
صباح الخير بدايه
الانباء اشارت الى انه سكان لبنان شعروا
بهذا الزلزال هل لك ان تصفي لنا او تنقل
لنا شهادات الناس حول
شده هذا الزلزال كيف شعروا به والفتره
التي استمرت به
بعض الفيديوهات التي تم تناقلها على على
الاجتماعي اظهرت ان هناك ايضا بعض
التفضلات التي ظهرت في الامنيه كان هناك
رعب لدى السكان الذين غادروا منازلهم رغم
الطقس العاصف ونزلوا الى الشوارع خوفا من
ان يكون هناك ارتدادات اكبر لما شعره
وارتدت يعني حوالي الاربعين ثانيه كان
هناك مده من الاربعين ثانيه التي هزت فيها
فيها الابنيه وبعدها كان هناك ايضا هزات
ارتداديه كان هناك خوف لدى الكثير من
السكان يقال انه انه السكان البقاع بها
اكثر من سكان باقي المناطق طبعا هناك تخوف
لان هناك ابنيه اصلا مهدده بالانهيار في
لبنان حتى الان لن نتاكد ان كان هناك
بالفعل ابني قد تاثرت بالهزه التي حدثت
ولكن بالفعل يعني هذا كان الاقوى
منذ منذ عشرات الاع
وهذا شعر بها المواطنون منذ عشرات الاعوام
ويذكر انها الهزه الثالثه خلال اقل من شهر
لكن عندما تتحدث عن انه هناك تصدعات بعض
السكان قالوا بانه حدد تصدعات في المباني
وان الهزه يعني شعر بها الناس لدرجه انهم
فروا من هذه المباني ونزلوا الى الشوارع
مده اربعين ثانيه تحدثت هل مازال الناس في
الشوارع ام انهم عادوا الى منازلهم
الى منازلهم الان خاصه مع الطقس العاصف
وخاصه انه الان نعلم ان اله تاتي بعد
الهزه الاولى تكون عاده اضعف مما سبق وقد
شعرنا بهذه الثانيه اضعف وربما ثالثه ولكن
يعني الان الجميع هذا اعاد السكان الى عدد
سكان الى منازلهم اذكر ايضا ان هناك
قويه الان في لبنان
رياح قويه وايضا الانضمام للامطار والثلوج
هذا الامر ايضا يعني لا يساعد الناس كثيرا
على البقاء خارجا هل سبق وان تحدثت بان
هذا الامر غير مسبوق منذ عشرات سنوات متى
اخر مره تاثر لبنان بزلزال من هذا النوع
كان مركزه في تركيا اذا كانت تحضرك
المعلومه غنوه
يعني لا تحضرني المعلومه ولكن تحضرني
الذكريات اعتقد انه قبل اكثر من 30 عام
يعني اذكر اننا شعرنا
بهذا من هذا النوع ونذكر ايضا انه كان
هناك يعني تتحركت حينها تحركت
اساس المنازل وايضا وايضا الابنيه ولكن
هذا هذا اليوم تتميز بطول مدتها يعني
بالفعل كانت
لحوالي دقيقه لم تتوقف
يتوقف الاهتزاز ولم تتوقف الابنيه من
الارتجاج المناطق التي شعر بها السكان اذا
كان لديك معلومه هل كانت فقط في بيروت في
الجنوب في الشمال ام في عموم لبنان شعر
السكان بهذه الهزه الارضيه
في الهزه يبدو انها ايضا كانت قويه لدى
الجميع لانهم يتحدثون يعني في اكثر من
منطقه خرجه المواطنون الى الشوارع وبقيوا
لدقائق
يعني في اماكن عامه خوفا من ان يكون هناك
ارتدادات اقوى ولكن في لبنان
يعني يبدو ان
يعني يبدو انه حتى الان لا يوجد اضرار في
الابنيه ولكن ذلك بطبيعه الحال لكن على كل
حال سنعود لك نعطيك فرصه لجماعه مزيد من
المعلومات شكرا حتى الساعه على هذه
المعلومات غنوه يتم مراسله العربيه كنت
معنا عبر الهاتف من بيروت ونتحول الان الى
اربيل وانضم الينا منها مراسل العربيه
احمد الحمداني احمد صباح الخير المعلومات
لديك كيف شعر سكان اربيل بهذه الهزه هل
كان لها تداعيات او تاثير
صباح الخير طبعا ابراهيم بالفعل شعرنا بها
وكانت بوضوح وهذه الهزه طبعا اللي مصدرها
تركيا
وايضا سكان محافظه دهوك شعروا بها وربما
اكثر اكثر من من اربيل
العراقيه التركيه
لكن على عموم دهوك واربيل وخروج خصوصا
سكان
الشقق والعمارات السكنيه خرجوا بشكل كبير
للشوارع او ايضا الامن الكردي اوصى وطالب
سكان شقق والعمارات السكنيه عن ان يبقوا
بالشوارع الى حين الانتهاء الهزه او
التاكد من عدد وجود هذا ثانيه بالتالي فان
الناس في الشوارع والعوائل والاطفال في
مناطق التي هي طبعا كما ذكرت في العمارات
والمناطق العاليه التي يسكنون الذين شعروا
طبعا تعرف
[موسيقى]
بالفعل طبعا التاثير لم يكن هناك اي اي
اضرار حتى الان على الاقل لم يكن هناك اي
تصريح او اي بيان او اي اشاره خصوصا وان
سلطات المحليه هنا
تحاول ان ان تتابع هذا الزلزال وتتابع
متداعياته وتتابع فيما اذا كان هناك اي
اضرار في مناطق مختلفه من اربيل حتى الان
لن تذكر اي اضرار ولكن
اللازمه نتابع فيما اذا كان هناك اي اضرار
خاصه في مناطق دهوك حتى الان لم يذكر لم
تذكر اي السلطات ولا المصادرنا ان هناك
اضرار يعني تسببت بها هذه هذا نتابع مناطق
الحدوديه وايضا المناطق التي هي في مناطق
شاهقه
وربما سيعود الناس الى منازلها بالفعل
الناس
يعني عندما عندما نتحدث عن ساعات الفجر
احمد هل يمكن القول بان الناس ربما
استفاقوا من نومهم على وقع هذا الزلزال ام
انهم كانوا يعني يسهرون انه هل كان طويل
درجه ان الاشخاص استفاقوا من نومهم
بالفعل كان طويل لدرجه انهم استفاقوا من
نومهم ونزلوا من العمارات والشقق السكنيه
الى الشوارع وطبعا بصوره
بصوره يعني بصوره مرسته يعني ان النزول
اعداد كبيره الى الشوارع او الى الساحات
والحدائق والباصات بحيث هناك
عمارات مدن كامله طبعا هي عمارات سكنيه
وبالتالي فان النزول غير مسبوق يعني
للناس في الشوارع وكل نزول غير مسبوق يعني
انه لم يحدث سابقا ان حدث زلزال في تركيا
في وسط تركيا وتاثر به الشمال العراق
ووسطه بهذا الشكل
بالفعل لم يكن هناك لم لم تسجل هناك اي
حاله
تركيا ونشعر بها طبعا
السليمانيه مناطق اخرى
فقط مره واحده قبل عامين واكثر على مواصله
هل هناك
لكن كنا في ايه ساعات ذروه طبعا كان هناك
حركه في الشوارع
والمساء الاولى بالتالي فكل الناس يعني
ناس كثيره في الشوارع وكنا نحن ايضا في
مكتبنا في العربيه بالتالي فان شعرنا في
المبنى ونزلنا للشوارع لكن في هذه الساعات
الساعات الفجر
وهذه هكذا شعور لم يكن مسبوق او خصوصا وان
الهزه اكثر شعرنا من مرات السابقه او
علاقات تقدير هي اقوى من السعه من من مرات
السابقه في اربيل والدهوك على اقل تقدير
طيب انا اشكرك حتى الساعه على كل هذه
المعلومات احمد الحمداني مراسل العربيه
كنت معنا عبر الهاتف اربيل